alors donc c'est encore PAF avec Babin
et nous sommes avec toute l'équipe avec
Pascal la tour duupin qui nous a fait un
résumé de ce qui s'est passé un samedi
matin vers 5h30 en Israël alors ça a été
dans l'actualité tout le weekend bien
entendu les chaînes info nont parlait
que de ça les chaînes normales aussi et
c'est vrai que il y a plein de questions
qu'on se pose on va se les poser avec
car ber dans un instant mais juste vous
quel est votre sentiment ici parce que
j'aimerais qu'on parle aussi de ce qui
s'est passé aussi de ce qui se passe
actuellement sur les réseaux sociaux et
cetera on voit beaucoup beaucoup de
choses circuler Gill quel a été ton
sentiment toi ce weekend l'ffroid euh
l'effroid de voir comme ça une
organisation terroriste attaquer des des
des gens massacrer des gens lesffroid
terrible et très vite tout de suite
cyril a la peur de la propagation de
cette haine au niveau mondial peur d'un
embrasement régional et et et peur que
les patients s'exacerbent et que ça
rejaillisse aussi en France bien sûr
solidarité totale avec les victimes
absolu mais tout de suite je me suis dit
que ça pouvait aussi fracturer notre
société qui est si fragile en ce moment
donc voilà les frroid par rapport à ce
qui s'est passé et une certaine peur que
cela arrive en France d'une manière ou
d'une autre avec une exacerbation des
sentiments
et j'espère j'espère que ça ne
débouchera pas sur une fracturation de
notre société voilà géraline je t
vouloir intervenir tout à l'heure oui
quand alors effectivement ou il est
frroid choqué par cette attaque massive
Barb est absolument immonde mais en fait
tout à l'heure vous montriez les images
de la rive avec ces jeunes et vous avvez
dit que ces jeunes ils étaient là pour
la paix pour voilà ils étaient pas là
pour faire de la politique ils avaient
pas de positionnement mais en fait c'est
pas le problème du Hamas en fait le
Hamas il est pas là pour savoir ce qu'il
pense il est là pour les anéantir parce
qu'ils sont juifs il est là pour raser
un pays c'est le projet c'est le sur
c'est le djihad du Hamas c'est leur
projet politique ils sont pas là pour
leur peuple non plus ils sont pas là
pour les Palestiniens ils sont juste là
pour faire disparaître un pays et faire
disparaître un peuple voilà et donc je
pense qu'effectivement Gil a raison je
pense que les prochaines peut-être même
années vont être très turbulentes très
agitées ce sera aussi compliqué de en
France parce qu'on on est un pays où t
tous ces thèmes là sont très exacerbés
en prenant parole ce soir la parole ce
soir on peut être soit courageux soit
lâche alors on peut être factuel mais en
prenant position ce soir en disant
certains mots ben je pense que on risque
on risque pour nous aussi je pense que
c'est des des thématiques justement on
va en parler dans un instant on va
parler dans un instant tout ça tout ce
qui voilà les menaces le plateau ici les
on a on n pas le droit d'ouvrir les les
fenêtres par exemple du studio parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a peur pour notre
sécurité donc ça ça devient carrément
fou donc évidemment voilà donc
évidemment très choqué et surtout très
très angoissé Yann mon cher Cyril ce
soir vous avez instauré une belle
solenité sur le plateau il y a pas eu de
musique il y a pas eu d'applaudissement
et ce que vous avez fait est très
important c'est la d'habitude on fait ça
quand ti un attentat sur le sol français
donc là on a tous pris la mesure que il
y avait quelque chose qui se passait
entre guillemets loin mais qui était
infiniment proche de nous et un jour
j'ai eu une conversation avec vous dans
votre loge et vous m'aviez dit que une
des raisons pour laquelle vous faisiez
cette émission c'est que vous vouliez
éviter cûte que cûte l'importation de ce
genre de conflit sur le territoire
français que vous aviez une mission vous
qui êtes tellement écouté par tous les
milieux toutes les castes de la société
et toutes les religions possibles que
vouliez vraiment incarner celui qui
voulait éviter l'importation de ce genre
d'événement sur le territoire français
et c'est aussi pour ça que cette
émission d'une certaine manière est
importante il y a quelque chose de très
important que les jeunes téléspectateurs
doivent savoir il y a deux institutions
palestiniennes il y a une institution
palestinienne officielle qui est en fait
les autorités palestiniennes
sjordaniennes qui reconnaissent comme
voisin et souvent comme ennemis les
Israéliens et il y a une autre autre
institution qui est terroristique et les
institutions terroristiques c'est une
sorte de de difficulté de joindre ces
deux mots mais c'est la vérité aussi au
Liban avec le hzbollah qui est une
institution mais qui va armer au
Parlement là il y a une entité qui est à
la fois institutionnelle et terroriste
c'est dans la bande de Gaza lorsque vous
amis musulmans chers Cyril vous ont dit
vous ont dit ça parce que moi moi mes
amis musulmans de quoi ils ont peur ils
ont peur que il y a un amalgame entre
mus
terror ils en peuvent plus de ça ça ils
en peuvent plus en France que quand
voilà et ça ils veulent plus de ce gen
d'amalg et ça leur fait beaucoup de mal
ce genre de chos mais si je peux me
permettre vous savez que la plupart des
Gazaouis c'est-à-dire des Palestiniens
qui sont dans la bande de Gaza pensent
comme vos amis musulmans simplement ils
vivent dans une dictature ils sont plus
proches la plupart des Gazaoui du
gouvernement israélien qu'ils ne le sont
des terroristes qui les humilient et qui
les bride sur la bande de Gaza toute la
journée et qui sont les gens du Hamas il
faut le savoir ils ne vivent pas dans
une dictature et vous savez dans toutes
les dictatures euh ils vivent dans une
dictature dans toutes les dictatures
vous savez comment on existe d'une seule
façon c'était vrai pendant la France en
1793 c'est vrai en Corée du Nord et dans
toutes les dictatures et en dans
l'Allemagne Nazi faire la guerre si vous
ne faites pas la guerre vous ne pouvez
pas obtenir de mandat officiel de votre
peuple et vous ne pouvez pas donner à
votre peuple ou soi-disant peuple la
moindre le moindre ordre si vous voulez
ils sont pris dans une sorte d'étau les
Palestiniens entre deux mots il faut
choisir le moindre mais je vous assure
qu'ils sont les Gazaoui dans le même lot
que vos amis musulmans ils aimeraient
bien ne pas avoir à choisir entre Israël
et le Hamas bien sûr on pense et on a
une grosse pensée bien sûr pour toutes
les familles hein des victimes et il y a
énormément aussi de de de personnes en
France qui ont de la famille là-bas et
qui sont très très inquiets de ce qui se
passe à tout moment c j'ai oublé parce
que c'est pour finir mon
raisonnement la haine du Hamas ne se
dresse pas quand contre les Israéliens
mais pas du tout elle se dresse contre
les Juifs pourquoi quand vous humiliez
des gens quand vous fr quand vous
crachez sur des cadavre vous ne crachez
pas contre des Israéliens vous ne faites
pas de politique vous avez bien vu que
ce n'est pas une attaque militaire ce
n'est pas une guerre de militaire envers
militaire dès lors qu'on s'en prend à
des civils on est dans la barbarie et
donc on ne s'en prend pas à des soldats
on s'en prend à des gens parce qu'ils
sont juifs ça veut bien dire que le
Hamas se moque complètement des
Israéliens et vous savez comment vous
savez comment le Hamas oblige les
Palestiniens dire le mot israélien ben
ce mot n'existe pas on dit juif en
général sale juif donc le mot
d'Israélien n'existe même pas dans la
langue du palestinien de Gaza Valérie
benim oui mais je je souscris à tout ce
que vient de dire Yan ce sont des
terroristes armés par des pays
totalitaires étrangers ils ne veulent
absolument pas soutenir la cause
palestinienne ce qui les intéresse c'est
pas deux états parce qu'on parle de
processus de paix ils ne veulent pas
deux états ils veulent éradiquer l'État
d'Israël et par là même l'existence même
du peuple juif ça c'est le premier ier
point donc effectivement le Hamas
confisque confisque la cause
palestinienne et les Palestiniens sont
les otages du Hamas et lorsque les le
les les terroristes sont arrivés sur le
sol israélien ils ont voulu tuer des
juifs ils ont voulu tuer le processus de
paix parce que en ce moment il y avait
également un processus de de
normalisation avec le Qatar avec
l'Arabie Saoudite pardonnez-moi et donc
évidemment ça ne les arrange pas et moi
à quel moment à quel moment ces images
ont ont confisqué l'humanité des uns et
des autres à quel moment les gens
certains n'ont vu que des juifs tués et
pas des êtres humains des enfants des
grand-mères des mamans et cetera parce
que quand je vois certains tweet oui
mais 8 mai ou mai à quel moment il y a
un 8 mai il y a une condamnation c'est
pas c'est pas le moment pour le 8 mai
exactement mais ce sera jamais ban il a
sepre il pas pardonnez-moi juste je
vrais terminer juste moi je pense que
cette histoire j'ai entendu c'est
l'affaire des Juifs et c'est l'affaire
des Juifs et et des Arabes c'est ni
l'affaire des Juifs ni l'affaire des
juifs et des Arabes c'est l'affaire de
l'humanité en ce moment par exemple à
Paris il y a une manifestation c'est pas
une manifestation qui est l'affaire des
Juifs c'est une manifestation qui est
l'affaire de tous tout le monde devrait
y être parce que à partir du moment on
vous demande pas d'être amis avec Israël
ou amis avec le gouvernement de
netaniaou on vous demande d'être ennemi
du du terrorisme donc si vous êtes
ennemi du terrorisme B vous pouvez
participer par exemple à cette
manifestation on posera les les cinq
questions dans un instant et d'ailleurs
on parlera de ce qui peut se passer en
France bien entendu avec tout ce qui se
passe là-bas aujourd'hui bien entendu
l'important c'est aussi d'avoir une
énorme pensée pour les victimes pour les
familles des victimes et pour ce drame
inomable qu'il y a eu samedi
et de baliier tous les sujets et
notamment le sujet de la prise de parole
sur les réseaux sociaux euh j'ai vu je
vous le dis moi je trouve ça admissible
voilà de voir des gens qui mettent le
drapeau d'Israël se faire insulter se
faire menacer de mort
actuellement il y a aussi des gens qui
ont mis le drapeau
palestinien euh hier avantiè et ça a été
sur les réseaux sociaux une guerre les
réseaux sociaux entre ceux qui mettaient
drapeau d'Israël ceux qui mettaient le
drapeau Palestine cette guerre des
réseaux sociaux c'est un fléo euh
sachez-le et moi j'ai eu je vous dis des
des centaines de sms vous le savez j'ai
j'ai voilà vous savez je je voilà je je
plein d'amis musulmans qui m'ont envoyé
plein de messages Cyril on est avec toi
Cyril c'est un
drame quand on voit ces guerres sur les
réseaux sociaux qui vont déboucher par
des guerres dans la rue par des des des
des actes barbarie dans la rue des actes
antisémites des actes racistes c'est
inadmissible je vous dis même dans les
écoles je vois il y a des positions euh
moi mon fils j'ai toujours envie que son
meilleur ami ce soit Eddie qui est de
confession musulmane j'ai pas envie que
demain ce soit plus son meilleur ami
parce que c'est un garçon que j'adore
qui est formidable et on lui demande pas
mon fils lui demande pas quelle est ta
religion s'amuse avec lui c'est un un
garçon qui qui a toujours été là ses
parents sont formidables ses parents
sont musulmans ils sont très en plus ils
sont très religieux voilà ils pratiquent
beaucoup et il est bien avec eux il fait
des fêtes musulman avec eux il est
content il fait les fêtes juiv avec nous
il est content on fait les fêtes voilà
j'ai pas envie de ça j'ai pas envie
qu'il y ait aujourd'hui en France quand
je suis avec mes potes tar ou qui est là
qui vient de m'envoyer un mot d'ailleurs
j'ai pas envie qu'il a de la défiance on
dis qu'est-ce qui se passe on n'est pas
là-dedans on connaît pas on peut pas
transporter ici un problème qu'on
connaît tous pas sur le bout des doigts
je vous le dis il y a pas une personne
ici ce soit dans le public autour du
plateau qui peut vous
donner vraiment tout les tenants et les
aboutissants de l'affaire trop complexe
c'est extrêmement complexe et on n pas
sur le terrain on sait pas donc on voit
quoi on voit ce que nous monre les
médias on voit ce que ce qu'on voit sur
les réseaux on peut pas on peut on ne
peut pas c'est comme je pense quand tu
es t quand tu es allé quand tu es
allé y tu allé en Corée Coré du Nord
exactement on tu avais vu plein de
choses d'ici quand tu es allé là-bas on
peut faire un parallèle c'est de voir
quand quand un peuple n'a pas voix au
chapitre ouais quand un peuple est
enfermé sous cloches non mais le truc
c'est je fais pas je fais pas un
parallèle entre les deux mais je te dis
que on on on nous dit plein de choses
aussi mais quand tu es sur le terrain
c'est pas la même chose là on ne peut
pas euh personne ne connaît le sujet sur
le bout des doigts il y a a on dit des
spécialistes en France on a r depuis de
jours on voit que des spécialistes sur
la PL la plupart des gens qui se qui se
déchirent sur réseaux sociaux sont
incapables de mettre la carte sur la
carte du monde l'endroit où se trouve
précisément Israël exctement aujourd'hui
on veut pas de guerre
euh en France entre les Juifs et les
musulmans moi j'ai pas envie voilà que
qu'il ait des tensions ça ça serait la
pire des choses vous remarquerez quand
même Cyril que ceux qui sont le plus
menacés en France aujourd'hui ne sont
pas les musulmans mais ce sont les
Israéliens ou les Juifs et pourquoi ils
sont menacé parce que ils ont été
victimes de cet horrible attentat samedi
dernier donc cela va
menace et tout est dit